[Music]
order order so who do we have here Your
Honor this is Cleopatra the Egyptian
queen whose lurid affairs destroyed two
of Rome's finest generals and brought
the end of the Republic Your Honor this
is Cleopatra one of the most powerful
women in history whose reign brought
Egypt nearly 22 years of stability and
prosperity oh why don't we even know
what she looked like most of the art and
descriptions came long after her
lifetime in the first century BCE just
like most of the things written about
her so what do we actually know
Cleopatra the seventh was the last of
the Ptolemaic dynasty a Macedonian Greek
family that governed Egypt after its
conquest by Alexander the Great
she ruled jointly in Alexandria with her
brother to whom she was also married at
him until he had her exiled but what
does all this have to do with Rome Egypt
had long been a Roman client state and
Cleopatra's father incurred large debts
to the Republic after being defeated by
Julius Caesar in Rome civil war the
general Pompey sought refuge in Egypt
but was executed by Cleopatra's brother
instead Caesar must have liked that
actually he found the murder unseemly
and demanded repayment of Egypt's debt
he could have annexed Egypt but
Cleopatra convinced him to restore her
to the throne instead we hear she was
quite convincing and why not Cleopatra
was a fascinating woman she commanded
armies at 21 spoke several languages and
was educated in a city with the world's
finest library and some of the greatest
scholars of the time mm-hmm
she kept Caesar lounging in Egypt for
months when Rome needed him Caesar did
more than lounge he was fascinated by
Egypt's culture and knowledge and he
learned much during his time there when
he returned to Rome he reformed the
calendar commissioned a census made
plans for a public library and proposed
many new infrastructure projects yes all
very ambitious exactly what got him
assassinated don't blame the Queen for
Rome's strange politics her job was
ruling Egypt and she did it well she
stabilized the economy managed the vast
bureaucracy and curbed corruption by
priests sent officials when drought hit
she opened the greeneries to the public
and passed a tax amnesty all about
preserving her kingdoms stability and
independence with no revolts during the
rest of her reign so what went wrong
after Caesars death this foreign Queen
couldn't stop meddling in Roman matters
actually it was the Roman factions who
came demanding her aid and of course she
had no choice but to support Octavian
and Mark Antony in avenging Caesar if
only for the sake of their son and again
she provided her particular kind of
support to Mark Antony why does that
matter why doesn't anyone seem to care
about Caesar or Antony's countless other
affairs why do we assume she instigated
the relationships and why are only
powerful women defined by their
sexuality order Cleopatra and Antony
were a disaster they offended the
Republic with their ridiculous
celebrations sitting on golden Thrones
and dressing up as gods
until Octavian had all of Rome convinced
of their megalomania and yet Octavian
was the one who attacked Antony annexed
Egypt and declared himself Emperor it
was the Romans fear of a woman in power
that ended their republic not the woman
herself how ironic
Cleopatra's story survived mainly in the
accounts of her enemies in Rome and
later writers filled the gaps with
rumours and stereotypes we may never
know the full truth of her life and her
reign but we can separate fact from
rumor by putting history on trial
you
[Music]